hey guys how's it going Justine here
we're back with another camera unboxing
and if you guys are like Justine you're
obsessed you have a problem you would be
a hundred percent correct but I have
this problem because I am trying to find
the perfect vlogging camera not only for
me but for you guys so I'm kind of here
just testing out everything possible and
I have a video coming up where I'm going
to blog with four different cameras same
video same place holding them all and
you guys can compare and contrast and we
can kind of do this together to see what
camera you guys like what you don't like
about each one and the cameras that I'm
going to choose comparison with is the
70d which I'm filling right now with the
Canon G 5x which I unboxed the other day
and the canon g7x which is the one that
most vloggers are currently using and
this one that I just picked up which was
actually a recommendation from some of
you guys this is the Canon EOS m3 and
this is a mirrorless camera with
interchangeable lenses so one of the
biggest complaints from some of you guys
is you're like that's really great but
if I'm spending so much money on a
camera that's small like this I want to
be able to take off the lenses and kind
of get a little bit more out of the
camera but yet I want it to be something
smaller than a DSLR so that is where
sort of the mirrorless cameras are sort
of coming into play and that's why a lot
of people are choosing these options
over the DSLRs but honestly there is
just there's so many options out there
that it's driving me crazy because I
want to test them all but unless
someone's going to send them all to me I
don't think that I can buy them all I
wasn't even going to do an unboxing but
I figured I would because I'd probably
be talking about the camera and you guys
won't want to see it so this one is the
one that comes with one of the kit
lenses 18 to 55 millimeter
I'm so excited like this is this is what
gets me excited I know all the girls do
their makeup hauls and their clothing
hauls
no thank you I hope something is not
supposed to be in that section because
there's nothing there
I feel like there might be something
that's supposed to be there okay um okay
I'm just going to take all the things
out and then we can sort through them
got our USB cable got a battery next
strap camera body let's open it up so
little by little I mean in comparison to
the DSLR it also has one of the flip up
view finders which is great for your
vlogging or shooting videos buy yourself
something that I have wanted these
little cameras to have is a microphone
input and guess what US cameras do have
a microphone input and I'm sure that's
the reason why Canon is refusing to put
them in this one because then no one
will want to buy this one you guys are
smart I get it but I'm losing my mind I
can't keep up guys so here's the lens 18
to 55 so it's just sort of basically
like if you've ever used DSLR camera
you've got the supply right here looks
like on the inside lock it into place
like so you'll definitely knows this is
clearly much bigger than the previous
little guys here because of the lens but
you can also get different lenses which
is going to be such a cool feature if
you want to do photos or do videos and
especially for me when I travel a lot
I'd like to try to find the most compact
system that I can just carry with me
that it works very easily pop the
battery in life so hopefully have an SD
card somewhere pitch him in there lock
you up
Tom y'all look at you guys do it a
little zoom in and I took a shot whoo
House nice diffic and a selfie
oh that was a nice shot a real nice shot
all right let's try and do a video one
of the things when I'm filming with a
DSLR the image stabilization for video
is usually not that good which is why I
love using sort of these smaller cameras
and it already looks like I can tell
them to image stabilization on this
little guy is definitely much better
than one of the DSLRs we'll see we'll
see okay so this is a video direct from
the EOS and three we can zoom in
who is it autofocus please please have a
nice focus oh definitely heavier than
the g5x which is here and way heavier
than the g7x
so a lot of times when people are
vlogging one of the things that is most
important is portability but also
depending upon what you're trying to
create
you're gonna want something that has
good audio straight off of the camera so
let's uh let's see how this audio is
shall we my first impression on the
onboard audio on the EOS m3 it's
actually pretty good and I'm in a pretty
big room and it's very echoey so I'm
sure using that in a smaller setting
it'll be a lot better also on this
current video I do have a volume turned
up a little bit which I did do in PO's
but in the clip that you just saw that
came straight from the EOS m3 I did
absolutely nothing to the audio did
nothing to the video so that was
straight from the camera so what you saw
is what you got and it's actually pretty
good now let's take a listen to what
this camera sounds like with an external
audio input I'm gonna unplug this
microphone so now we're gonna go to the
regular camera audio and put you on top
here plug you in my problems I can't
flip this up that's okay we get the
point um okay
alright here it is this is a microphone
test with the EOS and three using one of
the external mics and I'm pretty excited
because this is basically all I've ever
wanted in a camera is to have a small
portable camera with an external mic
option that's all I want that's all I
want guys this is it first impression of
what it
with the external microphone it's
clearly so much better and obviously
it's going to be because you have an
external microphone so that allows you
to have so many more options and clearly
have better audio so yes that is
definitely a big selling point yes
success there's a lot of accessories you
can also get for this there's an
external flash which you can just plug
in right here
and you can also get an external
viewfinders for those of you who are
used to shooting with DSLRs and you like
to have them you find your option but
most the time if you can see right here
you can basically see everything that
you see on that and just take your
photos like so and it's really nice I'm
real into it oh this also has a pop-up
flash too which is great that looks very
fragile so be very very careful what
that little guy puts you back down
there's a little button on the side you
can just push to pop that up this is the
EOS and three this was announced I think
last year and in comparison to the g5 x
the body size is almost identical thank
you guys for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this video one day soon there
will be the most perfect log in camera
ever but for the time being
we've got so many options and so many
different things that we can use right
now to make amazing quality videos so
it's kind of incredible the amount of
options that is out there right now so
you guys have any suggestions for me
please leave them in the comments below
and for now I'm gonna keep continuing to
test these out and I will hopefully have
a comprehensive video for you soon
giving some examples of everything and
different use cases and what I like and
what I don't like about each camera so
it'll help you guys make a better
decision if you're looking to get one of
these so yeah I'll see you guys in the
next ed bye I don't think this is gonna
work my confidence is very low for this
cooking endeavour how much house fire
start really yep okay listen I might
need you to stand by that is not a
churro